welcome to this special edition of
agenda today my exclusive one-on-one
interview with bassem youssef an
Egyptian heart surgeon turned TV
commentator turned champion a free
speech inspired by Jon Stewart's news
santia program The Daily Show on
American TV Youssef just a few months
ago commanded an audience of millions in
his country Time magazine caused him one
of the 100 most influential people in
the world well he is now off the air in
a country that imprisons journalists for
doing their job Yusuf's irreverent
tell-it-like-it-is style is a
non-starter and it's even put his life
in danger well that is not the case here
in Germany I just spoke to Yusuf at
Deutsche Welle global media forum listen
to what he says about his future the
future of his show and the future of
Egypt by the time the Revolution was
ending on the squares and streets of
Cairo another revolution was starting in
the most unlikely location in the
laundry room of the apartment of a young
cardiac surgeon with one desk one camera
trying to imitate a show he was addicted
to for many years
this young doctor on thought that just
by commenting on videos using fast
editing sound effects over the shoulder
photos and even on location reports that
he could make a political satire show
the show which was exclusively designed
for YouTube debuted on youtube on march
eight 2011 as the first egyptian
independent production on lived in a
country where internet penetration was
less than twenty percent and a youtube
video making fifty thousand views was
considered viral we began the b+ show
and in less than two months and with
only seven videos our channel made five
million views a figure unprecedented in
egypt and instead of just staying as an
internet phenomenon we made the next big
leap we made it to TV and we made a lot
of noise as we were at it alan become
when the calash way the headed in
Maggie's olympi landed and a gay
advocate McAlary oh and after just one
season we were one of the most watched
shows in Egypt we were still the most
watched on YouTube our channel reached
more than twelve hundred million hits
just after 15 months of our first
episode online I was invited on the set
the show have been blown following two
thousand dead a issue but it was more
than just a visit my guest tonight he is
a heart surgeon who also hosts a
satirical news program in Egypt called
al Bernama
wow you've got life audience yes so as
soon as we return to Cairo around August
2012 we decided to take it to the next
level and aimed at reducing Egypt's
first-ever live show with real life
wouldn't we managed to find a historic
piece of art in the heart of Paris
downtown grade with you designed by the
same architect in new design Radio City
I was in your neck of the woods just a
couple of weekends ago got me back in
the summer so I'm gonna come down and
see you are you guys taping in the
summer we eventually did it ladies and
gentlemen John soon after just the
second episode we became the most
watched program in the Arab world with
an estimated viewership of 30 million
heat-killed edition and that is just me
yes we go on every Friday night to take
a few punches at the ruling power possum
saved his best material for former
president Mohamed Morsi look at what
Morsi wore when he received an honorary
doctorate in Pakistan now look at how
blossom portrayed it on the air possum
was accused of damaging Egypt Pakistan
relations Egyptians across the country
laughed themselves silly but Morsi was
not amused by the hat joke a warrant was
issued for bassam's arrest he was
formally accused of insulting the
president and insulting Islam on the
thirtieth of June people took to the
streets to overthrow the Muslim
Brotherhood's regime and bassam was now
faced with a new reality that he should
continue with his message of satire
regardless of the circumstances it not
like any fake drafted
I wish I will be in Han and after one
episode of the programme the show was
taken off the air by the broadcasting
channel former friends became today's
enemies and so bassem youssef stood up
and did his show and made fun of the new
regime and they're funny hats and that
lasted a day in 2013 Bassin was awarded
the prestigious cpj award handed to him
by Jon Stewart fussing found another
network that was willing to take the
risk what do you think is going to
happen this summer you confident that
it's gonna be on the air show of hands
that we are going to continue without
stopping Jove as we are going to be
pulled off every soon and soon was too
soon the show only lasted 11 episodes in
its last season and even in its final
stretch the show stayed true to its
values it remained critical of authority
and it's biased media no matter how
difficult this became mysoline Phil I
feel it too like a live the lawsuit kept
pouring in and the show was even jammed
twice during em eventually
insurmountable pressures on the channel
and the team force the show to be
finally banned
when a table in northfield is naming the
hot desert oh they sell aqua oh I'll
evictees get them in a steamroller I
mean a hacker hatathli been aiming with
after the Salah wasn't it seems that
satire was too much for some people to
handle it seems that satire is not an
easy task after all my name is best and
Yusuf and I'm your host for tonight all
right possib you sir
enjoy it
this this is a great venue I mean I was
told this was the place for the Old
Parliament and one it was and then you
finish it and then you move to Berlin
that's right you have so much money on
your hands but you have not talked to
our director general then yeah hey we
gave you a live audience yes yes yes
it's always had nice to be in the life o
D&C just like it gives you the full
sensation that you're funny you've been
traveling a lot haven't you yes talking
like much you have a little bit of jet
lag oh yeah I'm totally jet lagged I'm
totally beaten we just came back from
Los Angeles and to this nice and very
sunny Germany totally like different
weather than very cold and cloudy Los
Angeles so you don't feel a little bit
of the LA son here in boa it's
everywhere it's like Orange County
everywhere I go I think it's like
Beverly Hills notes amazingly yeah you
have so much green here it's amazing
it's exactly like YouTube we have very
much money yes yes yeah yeah do you ever
wake up in the morning and pinch
yourself when you think about what has
happened in just the last three years a
lot and Anna and I do pinch myself and
sometimes I hit myself and sometimes i
have used myself because i don't know if
that if that was ever meant to be but
you know what we're off the air now and
I'm enjoying my days of unemployment so
I actually sleep till noon so i don't
wake up to pinching myself anymore it's
much more easier I know everyone here
wants to know about the future of your
show what's going to happen we're going
to talk about that in a second but you
have come with a message yes yes I so
they have to read from a paper and a
speech so I and III did that and there's
no teleprompter yeah there's no
teleprompter so it's gonna be very
difficult to write well all right there
you the floor is yours thank you
thank you very much for having me here
it was an incredible journey for me and
my team for us the show was a bit more
than a TV production it was a human
experience we experienced firsthand the
importance of satire in our daily lives
how was this a unique way to express
ourselves not through violence not
through instigating hate but through
comedy and light-hearted humor even if
that meant discussing the most daunting
and controversial political topics we
used humor laughter music to stand for
values of freedom coexistence and to
face both religious fascism and false
patriotism as we did that we made sure
to have fun and to enjoy ourselves and
that always reflected in our work and/or
our audience and even those who didn't
like our message still made sure to
watch us because they still enjoyed the
quality of work we were presenting they
would curse us later but after they have
already contributed to our TV ratings of
thank you very much Egyptians here will
relate I hate best music how we have to
win show us we did all of this for the
sake of a different meaning a media that
respected people's minds and
intelligence and in the same time
keeping them informed and helping them
to combat lies and misinformation that
plagued many of the media outlets as we
did that we never claimed to be freedom
fighters or political activists we
believe that it was enough to be the
normal everyday people who did not buy
into the everyday life of propaganda
that is full of lies and deceit satire
comes from the Greek word sarcasm which
means to flesh to rent to remove
someone's skin to reveal what's
underneath satire was our weapon to
dissect through the
eyes and rhetoric that were used to
control the people but those who were
too annoyed with us and with our message
used a different weapon the most
effective weapon of all fear fear sells
fear intimidates fear makes humans go
against their best judgment and make
them submit to the most basic instinct
of all fear we saw how those who hid
behind religion to manipulate the masses
used fear we saw how the basic human
needs to express oneself through logic
laughter and satire were demonized under
the pretense that this was against
religion against God and thus we were
deemed and holy obscene and even a
danger to the very fabric of society we
saw how fear was used by those who used
XD excuse of national security and the
false claims of patriotism to instigate
hate and mistrust between people and
viciously attacked anyone that said
anything different even if it was a joke
and thus we were also deemed and
patriotic viewed as traitors and
considered yet again as a threat to the
very fabric of society we saw how fear
made its way through people's hearts and
minds that even the most ridiculous and
illogical claims and conspiracy theories
we're widely accepted as undeniable
facts fear sells fear works fear makes
you get away with anything and when
people are afraid they will not accept
logic let alone satire fear can drive
the masses fear can turn them into
ruthless organisms devoid of human mercy
and IntelliJ intellectual logic fear can
drive humans give up their best ever
given trait humanity under fear they
accept taking away the right to object
to oppose and even applaud ticking away
others people rights and the fear
fascism becomes coveted and human rights
becomes an Indecent world our job was to
expose those irrational fears to dissect
through the unfair use of such you human
basic instinct in order to give up basic
human rights and needs
this might sound strange but AG again
let me remind you that fear sells fear
delivers fear is much much more stronger
fear might be the greatest mover of
masses ever you have experienced this
during your history the word has
experienced Nazism fascism McCarthy says
all were movements that used fears in a
phobia and empty vicious rhetoric 20 in
order to control the masses 60 years
later those techniques are still valid
we saw how the most advanced democratic
countries use fear to drag the whole
world into war like the Bush years in
America their main weapon was not a
state-of-the-art aircraft Criers or
stealth fighters but good old national
scare fear fear is the favorite weapon
of all democratic countries autocratic
country's religious states and terrorist
groups it's the favorite brand of all
fear cells fear works fear is a winner
satire and comedy might be one of the
very few antidotes against fear it
liberates reminds it sets your judgement
free and that is why it is a threat and
that is why people who use a satire will
be alienated marginalized or even scared
of it doesn't matter if it was a
government who thinks that they are
closer to God than you or a regime that
believes that there are more patriotic
than you you as a satirist has no place
in the world it is a word where fascism
is celebrated and where fear rules but
satire comes to disrupt such an equation
because when you laugh you cannot be
afraid anymore because and thus the
system will make sure to eliminate that
powerful weapon of laughter in order for
fear to set in but maybe there is a
small beacon of hope maybe change will
come from the most unexpected places the
word today is a young world youth are
connected now more than ever the
Internet and the open skies offers an
opportunity that was not there many
years ago when regimes can get away with
anything when we started on the internet
three years ago we might be the at that
time the only one in our country who did
that with such a unique idea
format but now the internet is full of
young people coming up every single day
to combat fear intimidation and media
deception we were too big to be allowed
to continue but by the time you were
banned the change has already happened
stopping the show might be viewed as a
sad ending but we would like to look at
it as a new beginning we have inspired a
whole generation to go out there and
express themselves in their own way the
all techniques of the 40s and 50s won't
cut it with those youngsters the
propaganda that word for their parents
generation won't be able to control them
anymore the plethora of fascism that
plays certain regions on the planet
right now is only a temporary a
transient moment of time that will be
soon washed away by the upcoming
generation fascists now is overwhelming
that you might think that the long
coveted freedom is stillborn but that is
not true as be even once said fascism is
not a new order of society it is the
future refusing to be born but I tell
you that the future is already here it
is just warming up so fear might sell
fear might work fear might win but it
will eventually face its defeat and the
battlefield for that glorious victory
will be no other than the hearts and
minds of vibrant inspired young people
who will not give in to fear
fear can only take you so far it is
unsustainable it cannot build nations it
only destroys and if you think if you
think that you might win today using
fear well think again because you're
mistaken because in the books of history
you will lose and in the hearts of the
young you have already lost thank you
very much
fear is definitely a weapon we were
talking yesterday um it was one
motivation for why you canceled your
show yes it is a great weapon and it
works and but the thing is you can only
direct fear and win with fear that much
you can intimidate a couple of people
many people basically but it's on the
other side it's an unsustainable and you
cannot just win forever it is not it's
it's a formula that has failed
throughout history and what when when
you look when you actually look at where
how we're living now you think it's it's
permanent but it's not it's just going
to take its time is going to be washed
away soon Roley you know you said the
the propaganda that had worked in our
parents generation would not work today
when we look at where Egypt is today and
compare it to 2010 it looks like that
propaganda is working very well
temporary it's it's more of a generation
gap a generation struggle and basically
because our parents still give us our
pocket money so yes it works so it will
just take its time and the thing is you
cannot rule the world of today with the
same way you did 40 to 50 s unless
you're in North Korea which basically
works for them pretty much hopefully
will not turn into North Korea we are a
very democratic free election countries
that actually works very well yes a
little bit louder there yes did you
underestimate the power that your show
had particularly I mean you know you
were threatened with the arrest when
President Morsi was in power but you
know you were showing the numbers 5
million hits did you realize that you
were a phenomenon
well the thing is I'm gonna actually
answer this through like a totally
professional way over actually someone
has a TV show if you let yourself think
of the effect that you have on people it
will actually interfere with how you
actually carry out your show every week
because it can blind your judgment it
can get into your head so we never
thought about a we're very influential
were so good you didn't think that you
were a fundamental part of the Arab
Spring no because we came after the the
Arab Spring I think we and many of
others where a manifestation of the Arab
Spring the Arab Spring came first and
then we we evolved after it so we were a
result of that and it was a blessing for
many of us who actually took a chance
and get our our voices out if you look
at the sea now even the media looks very
bad right now but if you look at the
scene of the internet it's a totally
different totally different platform
right now it's as if it's like why we
told this was 20 years ago no 23 years
ago what is your responsibility your
culpability in the demise of the Arab
Spring the demise of the iomega now I
feel very guilty now but the thing is
putting such a responsibility on a show
that came one once a week because people
use your argument saying like you had
their big role on overthrowing the
Muslim Brotherhood governed I tell let
me know what if that happens that mean
that they were a very weak of room it
doesn't mean that we are a very strong
program because this is TV this is
comedy and we can only go that far and
you can you cannot ignore so many other
factors and the and actually put it all
on on on a political satire show that
just comes once a week and I don't know
that a lot of people like to use that an
excuse but I think they're just
projecting their own weaknesses but I
mean as soon as the check the latest
changes as soon as they took place you
know actions came that led to the
cancellation of your show doesn't that
speak to the power so maybe the failure
of the Arabs
bring that led to the demise wash my
show no it's the other way around yes
there you know there's been a lot
written about you I want to ask you what
you think about this someone wrote you
like a number of Egyptians went beyond
opposing Muslim Brotherhood abuses to
supporting an anti-democratic
anti-liberal movement to exclude
Islamist from public life and ultimately
to replace them no because what happened
at the 30th of June was something that
was bound to happen after they
challenged the whole people I mean it
there again the Muslim Brotherhood
regime was unsustainable because and if
they were allowed to continue we were be
sitting here speaking how with my show
was taking off air or how I face this
Ridge it was just like a matter of time
but we never we never actually supported
something that's anti-democratic or
supported some any fashions or else I
would have actually stopped my show
after the Muslim brother wouldn't stay
at home but I came back on air I stayed
on message and that caused me to have my
show jammed twice and removed from air
twice so we were just doing our job
singing saying what's wrong is wrong and
we continue saying what's wrong is wrong
is do you believe that what about the
argument that you were your tent type of
humor your type of satire that it may
have been too much too early for
Egyptian society well this is the same
argument when you say what democracy is
too much too early for Egyptian society
and whenever paid people test it tells
me because I have this argument a lot in
Egypt and in the airports like oh we
love you but you know it's not your time
so I tell them so give me a date give me
a time well
so it's like all right 2019 second of
January when I mean give me give me a
time I'll stay home I'll go kayaking
until I get back in a give me five years
so and it's never a good time it's
always not a good time and this is
actually that this is the role of satire
it's it takes you out of your comfort
zone um really good from here I mean you
just came back you just came back from
the US again where do you go from here
does your show have a revival or what's
going to happen well we have decided
that actually continuing with a direct
political satire show every week talking
about present events might be not the
best thing to do right now and it's like
we basically am and not because I have
to fear or anything but you know because
that we think that it is not realistic
yeah and but we have our projects we
have we we have a company that has
managed to disrupt the the scene of the
media and the internet three years ago
and I think we can do it again we have
other projects it's there are other
venues and other path is that we can
take and there's all the way there is
always a way maybe it will take time
maybe it's better now to kind of you
know ease off stay it's too hot right
now and I mean I'm not talking about the
weather but a little bit hot right we
would you consider doing your so outside
oh I was asked this question so many
times of course it's much safer and much
easier to do and we were actually
offered so many times to get this show
outside we always tell people if you
take this show outside of the heart of
Kerry you lose credibility in a second
because the beauty of this show that
it's / Thank You Brandon thank you thank
you
the beauty of the show that it aired
from the heart of Cairo you had Egyptian
people coming from the streets of Cairo
have going through all of the everyday
grievance and coming on and listen to
you if you take it to what London Dubai
America you'll have people who are just
like you know experts and they don't
relate to you and you will viewed
instantly as a spy a criminal a traitor
whatever and that is not a good thing to
have and I would live my and I can still
do the show but I will show this show
doing the show as a fugitive and I don't
want I'm not in that stage and I would
share with everything yeah something
like an episode of lost or something yes
yes lost I I have to ask you that's the
night that well that's an idea right you
get on a plane and just crash it is
there used to be a show here in Germany
and the Germans will remember this it
was called first anz spas did it even
understand s joke but it was a comedy
show it well they were at it was a
comedy show in Germany yes good for you
I am very happy i hope you enjoyed is it
still on no yes that is not surprised
yes but do you have to make this car in
a funnier wage BMW with a smile ok yes
but do you do you think you helped
Egyptians to better understand humor and
the way it can actually fit into news
into understanding society well first of
all to the statement of us helping
Egyptian to understand humor is would be
very arrogant of me to say because it
seems we are I think we're very humorous
people and very funny by nature until
actually the joke is on you so everybody
is angry so but what we have done is
actually introduced a new format for the
for the region and to Uncle incorporate
serious news with
this attire sometimes deepest Otis the
tire was actually a new format and
people liked it and I think now I mean I
will give you an example of how that
changed I mean we're of the air now
right so now you go into the internet
and people to get take our own old
episodes and they cut our jokes and they
put it with the new videos happening
today so you know we ended but the show
still lives the idea still lives which
is great you have all of these people
expressing themselves either through our
show all through themselves so we as a
group of people a great idea and a
wonderful team we just put our best
effort in order to change the media
landscape whether or not we help people
to I mean I don't think we had people to
find their humor I think they will find
it themselves and then kill it by their
own meat I'm be until we have to wrap up
yes or no sorry we're taking too much
particular time sorry yes but let me ask
you as the doctor is laughter the best
medicine for bad politics oh yes it is
that's a good and with this ladies and
gentlemen great phrase we end our show
thank you very much yeah thank you
giving her a round of applause
and my next guest is another Egyptian
who is trying to work in his country's
very challenging media environment he is
a photographer he is a blogger and his
images are world famous and that has
made him this year's Bob's Award winner
for the best blog in online activism now
the blog documents civil turmoil in
Egypt over the last three years and
right now we'd like to take a look at
some of Musab el shamah nice work in his
blog Mosab al shami tells stories
exclusively through photographs since
the start of egypt's of jeavons in 2011
as shammy has been documenting
developments using only his camera he
shows many sides of the conflict not
just one his work has been published in
international media outlets but
primarily it's the Egyptian public he
wants to reach as Shami has vowed to
continue his work and keep telling
stories about all Egyptians yeah a
storyteller indeed Mosab is here with me
now at the global media forum
congratulations thank you very much
what's up on weddings good to have you
with us what does it mean being uh Bob's
Award winner well it's a great honor
honestly and I think it's it's quite a
recognition for for the work I do
especially at a time like this i think
the timing does really tell a lot
because obviously egypt is going through
a very difficult time especially for
those who are trying to tell what's
happening whether they're journalist /
bloggers or activists it's it's a very
tough time and and it couldn't have
become at a more bittersweet occasion I
mean we're going to talk about the you
know the political situation in Egypt
just a second but you being able to tell
this story is is a reflection of how
important digital media has become in
the Middle East and in Egypt I mean 10
15 years ago you wouldn't
been able to do the job you're doing
today would you yeah I mean it's it's
it's it's been a ride really for every
every digital journalist you know
whether the citizen journalist or four
for the journalist or activist online
it's it's it's like they have found this
outlet you know that to finally reach
out to people and finally put their work
out there without all the censorship or
without the needs for a publisher and I
think this has this has boosted a lot of
a lot of people's career you know people
who had everything except a place and
and all of a sudden they had is this
atmosphere and this place that gave them
the ability to show their work and to
interact with with others and even in
some cases editors and top journalists
are you able to defy censorship in Egypt
in your home country I guess it's it's
their work is a bit more difficult now
with with the internet obviously and
then I mean is it change has it changed
since the new president came into power
well I don't think they have they I mean
obviously they're trying to gradually
control what sort of contact the content
that can be published on on social
networks and Twitter and they're all
these laws that that are currently been
in the process of sort of in the making
but there is a strong strong movement
online of bloggers and activists who
have done this for 10 years or or even
more and and they're using all all means
possible to you know put and put the
news out there and try to evade all the
new measures that's what Boston Joseph
said earlier today when when he was
giving his talk that that the censorship
and the propaganda past generations that
they're not going to work with this
generation absolutely I think despite
the very harsh attempt they're going at
the moment it's just going to be
impossible to you know sensor this
generation they have so much energy and
so much tools that they're just not
going to give up on not to mention that
this is a generation that had just gone
through a revolution and
and it had you know affected every
single person of them so it's going to
be impossible to shift the time back
despite the very serious stem suit
that's in Egypt what's your take on the
cancellation of awesome use of show you
know you said you've watched it it was a
huge force in Egypt and now it's gone
yeah I think it was very symbolic of you
know the measures that can be taken as
for someone like Bassam who had had
millions of viewers and and the huge
international report winding and all of
a sudden he is not his not there anymore
you understand why he canceled the show
I mean it he did he did cite personal
you know concern over his his safety and
and his family and and it's completely
understandable do you about that for you
too though I mean if you know obviously
a pictures paint a thousand words I
think every person in Egypt who is not
following the general and official
narrative should be very concerned and
and as a as a photojournalist who's
trying to who's not only facing the
risks on the street you know been in the
middle of clashes and trying to to
document what is happening but also when
it comes to a personal safety and the
threats that are there you know been
directed at activists and and add this
at the current state of not accepting
other than the official narrative and
this has been able and they have been
able to put hundreds of activists and
journalists and photographers behind
bars including your brother yes
thankfully he was finally released but
he but it was a very difficult time for
the family we went through ten long
months of detention and Abdullah started
his hunger strike in January and if not
for this hunger strike you know who
knows for how long he would have been
there well let's tell people about about
your brother Abdullah he's an Al Jazeera
journalists he is one of the journalists
at well you know we've been reporting on
yeah who has been in prison in in Egypt
and he was released but he's been on a
hunger strike yeah abdallah we got his
hunger strike around five months ago in
January because of his detention he had
no
official charges against him and there
was no prosecution interrogation there
was no trials so he was just there you
know and and having his detention sort
of automatically renewed and after six
months of this he finally decided to go
on this hunger strike and he had lost
approximately half of his weight and and
and has had serious concerns and and an
international outcry that sort of helped
him but unfortunately his he still got a
very long a lot longer to remember I was
he doing if you talk to him since he was
released yeah I mean thankfully I was
able to to see him before coming here
for the for the ceremony and it is a
massive boost for the family to have him
finally they're after almost a year of
been behind bars it's it's a very
difficult experience for the whole
family you know not just for him but it
was very unfortunate that just few days
later his colleagues at al Jazeera
English were sentenced to seven years
and yet we talked with a drug lingo yeah
journalism obviously runs in your family
yeah is there a promising future in
Egypt for journalists I think there is
because because of how sort of easy it
has become for people interested in
practicing journalism whether it's
photojournalism whether it's it's
writing whether it's reporting and the
wave of citizen journalism that began in
that you're in the revolution of the 18
days and you know it's even later made
the revolution become known as the
internet or Facebook revolution there's
there was there was in a huge potential
for people who want to you know practice
journalism in a non-traditional way and
I think it's it was able to give a lot
of people this opportunity that I
mentioned including myself I don't think
if the revolution hadn't happened I
probably would have still been a
pharmacy student
right i mean so you were those big
changes that came through yes absolutely
it was and you know did it it was it had
a massive personal effect on on people
including me and thousands of youth is
the Arab Spring over is there a positive
post script that we can talk about well
for the time being it looks well
defeated whether it's over or not is is
is you know that's yet to be to be told
but it's a very gloomy and dark period
not just in Egypt but across the Arab
world and despite the the frustration
that has hit many youth who have three
months three years ago where you know
living the euphoria after of the
revolution it looks like it's going to
take a very long time and it's going to
be a much tougher process than than
expected but I think there is still
massive determination within the youth
and and the human rights campaign Egypt
is still pretty much alive even though
it is it is facing a very early where's
this positive outlook coming from though
I mean a lot of people argue that Egypt
today is basically where it was four
years ago yeah I think they're right
because what's going on in Egypt is is
nothing less than than terribly
concerning i think is so you have me be
positive in about a positivity i will
say comes from the presence of these
youth who despite all of this i mean it
depends on how you really want to see it
but by interacting with many many youth
who until today are hopeful that one day
they will be able to turn the tide
around and and they really do have a
point because also three years ago it
was extremely depressing and gloomy as
an Egyptian and within 18 days they
history was made so I wouldn't
completely count on on things been
done and dusted but it is very difficult
I all I will admit that is there any
particular photograph any any project
that your proudest of well i'm mostly
proud with with the with the pictures i
made during the the post-revolution
months during the entire square most
most of the pictures that i did while
while chasing my own personal project I
I am particularly fond of a couple of
pictures that were taken during clashes
near Tahrir Square most especially a
field that symbolized for me what the
revolution wore one of them was a
picture of a fireworks exploding near
the Minister of Interior during clashes
and it it did show this brief moment of
you know the beautiful mess of the say
of the revolution another one there is
also some lesser positive ones but have
also been very significant because I've
had to hold these stories along with me
and through these pictures I was able to
know the people in them and we later
even made these bonds so it is it does
really stay with you as a photographer
and it does affect you for a very long
time and that's what it's supposed to do
well congratulations again on winning
this award good luck to you in the
future I'm good luck to your brother
thank you thanks for stopping in to talk
with us thank you today it's good having
you on the show with us that is going to
wrap up this edition of agenda from the
global media forum here at the world
congress center here in bonn germany
remember we'd love to hear from you tell
us what you think about the show you can
email me you can write to me on facebook
or you can send a tweet to me you can
write to me there Brent Goff TV and
don't forget you can watch the show
again on YouTube I'm Brent Gogh join me
next time when I set the agenda
you